I got involved with history from the
Encyclopedia of Boston so watching all
these guys watching all these guys and
one day we were at the table
and all the fighters with their
customers at the head and this guy said
something about Alexander today he said
back in Alexander the Great time he was
six six he was a monk so I thought and
my subconscious said who's that guy
Alexander he said boom who is that guy
that's as soon as we finishing eating I
was looking the guy up trying to find
but I went to back there you went to
libraries
and so I found out his story
and um ever since then I put myself in
this situation I I was subconsciously
Alexander the Great